eugene lancel lannister we are here
today to talk about game of thrones and
we have a new little quiz
our new quiz is marry murder
or make out that's wonderful i'm gonna
give you three names
okay okay and then you are as lancer
lannister gonna have to tell me who you
would marry
murder and make out with okay so first
first steps we've got three coming up
first set of names is brienne tyrion
and tywin so brienne tyrion and tywin
who would you marry who would you murder
and who would you make out with
it's so funny that i can say i could
potentially say tywin or tyrion because
there's so much incest in the show
anyway lots of like lots of could be gay
so i suppose
yeah make out with uh
make out with with tyrion marry um
marry brienne and and uh murder tywin i
think that's fair yeah exactly i think
that's
murder the uncle the men of the uncle
get him out the way maybe a bit more
power to come for you
yeah well then exactly well then dan
well then dad's in the lead for
for for casterly rock so it's a very
good idea actually
and then i oh my god that's a brilliant
idea yeah that's what i should do i
think you've hit on something here
yeah that's what i should do suggestions
to writers
that's my plan okay next one right
melisandre
littlefinger or varys marry murder or
make out melisandre littlefinger or
varys
i would probably um
well i don't think uh i would probably
marry
uh no i'd probably marry i probably
married various actually because imagine
all that gossip
imagine all the gossip you can get in on
maryvaris make out with alexandria and
uh murder littlefinger yeah because he's
uh he's a conniving little man no no
and as they said in uh they said already
in season three if we didn't know
he's such a dangerous the most dangerous
man in westeros yeah you know he's very
very good he's very good at convincing
you he's got nothing up his sleeve where
in fact
there's there's up his sleeve so he's uh
no i think that would be my order
i like that i like it now final one
marry murder or make out
bronn stannis and joffrey
bronze stannis and joffrey marry murder
or make out do you know what i'm going
to say
when when um there was a scene when uh
when uh
peter walks in after sansa is being
unfortunately uh beaten in front of
joffrey and
and um jerome and uh and i
had this moment that didn't make its way
on camera but he was walking in
and he gave me these death stares as i
was walking looking at him
as his character and i thought oh great
i hope that makes his way in because
then lance can sort of cower away
so for that sake murder murder bronn
i know murder bronn um uh
and and there was joffrey who else uh
there was joffrey and stannis and
stannis uh murder
yeah murder bronn um
oh this is so tricky i'd have to uh
it probably makes sense to me marry
joffrey and
uh make out with renly because um
oh stannis oh um yeah still make out
with stannis just just just to wound his
pride and mine but that's that that
would still happen you might have a bit
of competition from melisandre but
you know you could you could get in
there i've already made out with her
that's true yeah
she might be devastated just from that
already apparently answers with him a
broken woman because you've left her now
what cersei would be now yeah i mean we
all be heartbroken that'd be a great
story actually but i can't believe
that you would murder braun and marry
joffrey
i know well that's what he gets for
death staring me and on that
bombshell thank you very much thank you
very much indeed
you